[Musique]
du matin
Émilie commence sa journée
[Applaudissements]
on va plier les jambes 1 2 voilà allez
encore une fois 1 2 3 voilà comme tous
les jours elle rend visite après de 45
patients autour de Béville-le-Comte
à la fin du mois on change d'heure
allez
quel que soit la météo Émilie fait sa
tournée un planning serré qui laisse
pourtant la place à des moments de
complicité elle parcourt près de 300 km
dans la Beauce tous les jours
le matin c'est
pas avoir les deux filles dans le même
sabot ça on va vite c'est vraiment
physicien c'est prise de sang
diabétiques et puis après il y a les
gens qui vont travailler donc du coup
faut pas faut essayer de pas être en
retard pour pas non plus eux les mettent
en retard
à 35 km au nord dans la vallée de l'Eure
Maïté commence aussi sa tournée chez des
patients atteints de maladies chroniques
j'ai les mains froides cette patiente à
la maladie de Parkinson et le suivi dans
la prise des médicaments est très précis
alors là je note du coup on répertorie
tous les jours
le début de la machine le cava recevoir
en Mg comme produit sa tension parce que
c'est un produit qui provoque des
hypotensions et l'endroit où on pique le
site où on pique voilà donc tout est
répertorié pour avoir une traçabilité
dans sa tournée Maïté vérifie les
traitements réalise les suivis de
pansement les prises de sang ou les
tests PCR
c'est
pour demain d'accord
sauf quand elle fait des piqûres bien
sûr
il faut
être un peu psychologue et voir l'état
du patient et puis voilà pas rêver comme
un gendarme et puis donner votre bras on
fait la piqûre on s'en va et puis voilà
on est quand même des humains et on aime
bien le contact des autres justement
là c'est la liste de tous les patients
du jour oui ça c'est ce matin donc là
[Rires]
[Musique]
Maïté a quitté l'hôpital il y a 4 ans
pour rejoindre un cabinet d'infirmière
aujourd'hui elle ne regrette pas sa
décision
les conditions à l'hôpital
est en ce qu'elles sont en travaillant
en réanimation en fait je n'avais de
moins en moins de temps auprès du
patient beaucoup de temps où il fallait
faire un peu le travail que le cadre
faisait à un moment et qui ne faisait
plus c'est à dire faire les bons de
commandes pour le matériel tout ça donc
c'est énormément de temps qu'on avait
plus auprès du patient et on m'a proposé
ma proposer ce poste sur le coup j'avais
refusé puis après je me suis dit mais en
même temps j'ai besoin de de changement
j'ai besoin de voilà de faire mon métier
comme moi je j'aimerais le faire donc du
coup j'ai fait une journée de
d'observation avec cette collègue et
puis ça m'a plu je me suis lancée
[Musique]
bonjour les filles bonjour monsieur
Émilie dépose des prélèvements à la
pharmacie l'occasion d'aborder le cas
d'une patiente de 85 ans qui a besoin
d'un lit médicalisé
pour qu'on voit comment on peut
s'organiser je vais voir avec elle j'ai
pas encore été la voir je vais la voir
et puis et du coup je vais voir pour
qu'elle appelle son fils ouais j'ai son
numéro
[Rires]
donc dans ce cas là et là c'est vraiment
le côté rural on va se débrouiller avec
un voisin là avec Salvador le
préparateur de la pharmacie qui peut
intervenir pour donner un coup de main
donc là c'est en dehors du côté
pharmaceutique mais on est présent pour
nos patients et le plus important c'est
que le lit soit installé au plus vite
j'en ai une qui travaille à Orléans qui
fait des livres et puis l'autre a fait
des robots là vous savez des robots qui
coûtent super cher ah oui donc même le
weekend elle travaille pas trop de
bulles l'infirmière c'est un lien un
contact avec l'extérieur pour les
malades parfois la seule personne que
les patients voient dans leur journée en
plus des traitements émilie est un
soutien au quotidien au début que
j'étais très malade vous aviez appelé le
professeur
tout ça il s'occupe de tout quoi enfin
c'est vrai que ils font pas que le soin
il s'occupe de tout le après quoi
heureusement qu'elles sont là parce que
franchement voilà
je peux plus aller nulle part sans
eux
j'ai tellement mal aux mains que je
pouvais même pas faire la seringue comme
elle fait
donc sans eux je suis perdu
c'est vrai il faut le dire
[Musique]
on rentre vraiment dans l'intimité du
patient à l'hôpital c'est les patients
qui sont en fait voilà dans un dans un
milieu cadré nous on rentre vraiment
dans leur intimité et c'est vrai que des
fois c'est pas très facile il faut être
un petit peu psychologue aussi il faut
sentir les situations
la dame elle était à fleur de peau du
coup
des fois on voit on parle avec les gens
on voit quand on les connaît parce que
c'est pareil quand on les connaît pas
bon bah du coup de fond se rend pas
spécialement compte mais à partir d'un
moment où on les connaît c'est vrai
qu'on se rend compte qu'ils sont pas
bien et on essaye de discuter on prend
le temps avec eux voilà donc c'est on
peut rester 10 minutes chez les gens
comme on peut rester une demi-heure on
sait quand on arrive on sait pas quand
on part
Emilie retrouve Sophie la pharmacienne
chez la patiente de 85 ans pour
l'installation du lit médicalisé il va
falloir
moi je j'espère que vous allez bien
installer parce que ça commence à
devenir difficile
donc on va voir ça on va voir comment ça
se comment ça se passe là-bas et puis
après si vous avez fini on va vous
installer au lit
l'infirmière a dégagé une heure dans sa
tournée pour installer sa patiente car
le transfert est délicat
j'ai peur vous avez peur maintenant
ouais bah oui vous avez mal allez-y
ça va
j'en peux plus
moi
en dessous
et on va la lever un peu
mal oh
c'est fini du coup donc pour Madame là
donc j'essaie d'appeler le médecin bon
là je viens d'essai de la joindre j'ai
pas réussi mais il doit être en
consultation
essaie de lui envoyer un SMS moi
j'essaie de le joindre parce que là du
coup il faut vraiment lui mettre des
antidouleurs c'est plus possible bon la
première qui a des nouvelles
[Musique]
du médecin
ok bah pas de souci ben je vais essayer
de le joindre ça roule on fait comme ça
voilà et ben à tout à l'heure à tout à
l'heure je reviens j'ai des PC a déposer
à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
dans la vallée de l'Eure Maïté finit sa
matinée de travail
qui s'est formée le corps fabrique la
fibrine pour cicatriser au plus vite
sauf que en réalité ça empêche la
cicatrisation donc il faut retirer cette
cette peau blanche pour permettre une
meilleure cicatrisation
ça doit être les premiers fils de d'en
dessous en fait
ça prend combien de temps un pansement
comme ça
un quart d'heure 20 minutes après enfin
plus ou moins c'est là comme il y avait
un peu de
un peu de fibrine à retirer des fois ça
peut prendre un peu plus de temps oui
demain matin sera mon collègue du coup
pour la prise de sang je pense vers 7h30
c'est bon
il n'est jamais venu ici au courant pour
pour kiwi mais bon comme ça un homme il
devrait être tranquille bon bah bonne
journée merci au revoir on n'est pas
payé à l'heure on est payé à l'acte et
donc non c'est pas c'est pour ça que
faut généralement faut être rapide mais
efficace et puis tout en parlant aux
patients et puis les soins c'est toute
l'année et 7 jours sur 7 seul il est
difficile d'assurer ce suivi c'est pour
ça que les infirmières en libéral
préfèrent partager un cabinet à
plusieurs
bonjour
c'est la pause déjeuner Maïté retrouve
Stéphane et Claire l'infirmière qui a
proposé à Maïté de passer en libéral on
est dans la obligation de la continuité
des soins donc nous si on passe pas chez
le patient alors qu'il a une piqûre à
faire tous les jours on peut pas donc si
on est tout seul on est obligé de
travailler tous les jours donc c'est
pour ça que le fait d'être à 4 ça permet
quand même d'avoir à côté une vie
familiale et une vie professionnelle et
vraiment faire la distinction entre les
deux
[Musique]
il faut prendre en plus une prévoyance
et il y a l'essence il y a tout ce qui
est les assurances voilà donc tout ça
mis bout à bout au final
plus de 50% de ce qu'on gagne par voilà
dans les charges
garder sa patientèle tenir le rythme de
la tournée en gardant le sourire c'est
parfois
difficilement c'est ça aussi qui est
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui situation
difficile avec la petite dame qu'on a
installé le lit et c'est vrai que
psychologiquement ça ça prend beaucoup
et je pense sérieuse mon énergie
j'en ai pourtant j'ai quatre enfants
j'ai de l'énergie mais là
sur les routines
malgré les aléas et Minnie et Maïté
retrouveront leur voiture leur patients
et les routes de Eure-et-Loir infirmière
une profession qui souffre d'un manque
de reconnaissance et pourtant en milieu
rural ce métier est crucial ces femmes
soignent créent du lien et
s'investissent pour le bien de tous